president biden backing the idea of
major league baseball moving it's all
star game out of georgia over the
state's new election law
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsibly
i would strongly support them doing that
this is jim crow
on steroids what they're doing in in
georgia
and 40 other states what it's all about
are you gonna close a polling place at
five o'clock when working people just
get off
hmm biden has repeatedly blasted the new
law but what he's saying
about it is flat out false the liberal
washington post even gave him four
pinocchios for some of his claims
governor brian kemp telling the
president to get his facts straight
the president ought to be smart enough
as well or certainly his
people that are briefing him to tell him
what's actually in the bill because when
he made his comments earlier
he didn't know but it also could be that
he doesn't care
i think the people are standing up and
realizing the games that are being
played here
and they're going to be fighting back
with us
all right lawrence jones there's been a
lot that has been said by the president
and his administration about this
georgia bill and now stacy abrams is
basically saying no no we don't want a
boycott of georgia
please no so a couple things here my
favorite part about the washington post
article was when they posed the question
they break down
every single thing that biden said and
they left with the question where did
biden get this from
and the article says we have no clue in
other words
he just lied about it but the democrats
are in a big pickle right here now
because now the the talking points have
shifted to this boycott
you're going to boycott atlanta the
modern day black wall street
you're going to come after them tyler
perry and all the black entrepreneurs
businesses that are in london that is
that is the new position of the
democratic party so i think there's a
lot of people in georgia and
atlanta specifically because when people
come to georgia they come for atlanta
that's where all the businesses are
going
the modern day black wall street so if
that's the position that democrats want
to go
okay let's take it but the republicans
have a problem also
because although the democrats are
factually wrong
when it comes to the legislation the
republicans have a problem with the
ground game
in georgia and i warned people this in
the past
election i went on air every single day
and said there is this surge going on
right now with voters
and black voters are showing up for the
democratic party
so the republicans have to provide
alternatives for black america
you got all these entrepreneurs there
that believe in a free market
right if you really believe in liberty
then go
out there and sell it to those people
because changing this legislation is not
going to help you in the next election
if they get more people to show up and
vote
that is a great point dana but back to
the boycott you have a number of these
big companies that are based in atlanta
delta for example putting out a
statement and now all the sudden it's
like oh do i not need
an id to get on a delta flight anymore
is that also racist to ask for id when
you go to the airport
well even worse well first of all the
voter id issue is actually
quite bipartisan not only in the state
of georgia
but all across the country in fact most
democrats seem to agree with that so i
don't see why they're hanging their hat
on this one
stacy abrams had bought the jim crow 2.0
domain name before they even knew what
the final bill was going to be
so this was all telegraphed how the
republicans got surprised
that this was going to be the play is
beyond me and why they didn't provide
any air cover
to people like you know companies like
delta and i'm not i'm not
going to give delta a pass either they
they were participants in the bill they
had no problem with the bill until
three or four days after the bill was
passed then the twitter mob came and
they were like
uh oh and now now they're in a pickle as
well
so it's a it's a mess and let it just be
a warning to all
states this is coming for you because
every state is working on redistricting
they've got the gerrymandering things
because it's after the census
they're working on tightening up voter
laws
however that's all being framed as voter
suppression all across the country
so from the communication standpoint i'm
like you better
take a shot of espresso and get out
there
and explain things they could have
explained this so much better my last
thing is
president biden repeated word for word
what he had said
before um but in the middle of that the
washington post gave him four pinocchios
i would be so embarrassed i'd be so
ashamed if i ever got a pinocchio
let alone four i would never say it
again but then they repeated it
at the white house briefing today so to
me that's like coordinated
it's unbelievable yeah no pinocchio's no
pinocchios or dana ever but speaking of
the white house briefing today
jenn saki repeated the lie again take a
listen
it gives options to expand it right but
it's standardized at five
it also makes it so that outside groups
can't provide water or food to people in
line
right it makes it more difficult to
absentee vote
are those things all correct so no our
tone is not changing
so juan they keep lying about this idea
that you can't provide water to people
in line it's just a certain
number of feet away from the voting and
polling place like anything else you
can't
campaign you can't give out things for
free so why do they keep lying about it
that's not a lie i'll tell you what the
big lie is here the big lie
is donald trump said the last election
was stolen
and it was a result the steel was the
result of election fraud
and now you have republicans in georgia
and
other state legislatures who were saying
oh yeah we want to reassure
voters who may have lost confidence in
the election system
by changing the election system again
let me reiterate
there was never any evidence of election
fraud
to sustain what the president said about
this being a stolen election
and now there's no argument there's no
factual argument about the idea that the
georgia legislature
has now removed stripped power from the
secretary of state
that they now have power to absolutely
undo
local boards of elections in georgia
counties
when they think that something is wrong
when they think gee you know we
shouldn't have lost this election
all of a sudden there they have the
power to overturn elections
to me this is awful and i think that's
why you see
coca-cola that's why you see delta
that's why you see people involved with
the big sports teams and in the all-star
game
saying you know what this doesn't keep
with our values that this is a democracy
you show the boycotting impediments
in the world you're for the boycott you
know what
i know stacey abrams is not for a
boycott
but i'll tell you this you saw yesterday
in the new year's dreams
page by the top business top
black business leaders in this country
lawrence
and what did they say the black business
leaders in atlanta are
saying they don't want business come on
juan the black business leader you got
to get sean in here
let me ask you a question so my wife's
of hispanic descent rachel right and
i'm white so if i go to her and say
listen you're too stupid because you're
a hispanic to get a license
or an id and i can't cause i'm white
guess what's going to happen in my
marriage
uh it's not going to go very well this
is this is so ridiculous and so racist
that
democrats say we can't get id's because
of the color of our skin and one last
point i can't wait
for for coca-cola and delta at the next
shareholder meeting to say
we're not going to verify people who are
owners of the company when they vote
vote on shareholder proposals
and for the board of directors anyone
can come in and vote i guarantee you
they'll get their pant suit off what's
good for delta and coke
and the way they run their corporations
is as good for for
georgia and for america voter id works
and it works for coke and works for
delta
indeed it does and most people support
voter id okay